faites du bruit pour accueillir julia
lopes
[Rires]
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir [ __ ]
c'est impressionnant c'est vraiment
impressionnant déjà je voudrais
commencer avec un petit d'une petite
touche
j'aurais juste dédié ce tedx à tous nos
amis et tous nos proches qui sont partis
trop tôt qui nous regardent depuis
là-haut fait sur youtube dans 5 g en
tout cas merci à toute l'équipe de tedx
veut aussi dire ça parce que c'est une
super organisation c'est la deuxième
édition mais recyclé pour mercy jérémy
et surtout aussi merci tous les
bénévoles parce que sans eux n'ont rien
pu faire pour les applaudir vraiment
vraiment vraiment et puis un autre truc
aussi je pense qu'il ya d'autres gens
que vous pourrez applaudir parce que
c'est incroyable on avait quatre cents
places que j'ai depuis combien à vendre
à son parti comme ça donc je pense que
vous pouvez faire du bruit pour vous
aussi monsieur vraiment c'est cool ça
fait plaisir
comment se mettre la pression encore
publicitaires c'est un peu le thème de
mon sujet de mon tedx donc ça va parce
que je sais pas vous mais moi j'ai des
peurs qui - ebay la peur d'aimer la peur
d'échouer de me blesser voire même de
mourir
cette peur intense en fait qui nous
hante depuis notre plus jeune âge fait
malheureusement pour moi l'expérience de
la mort est une étape que j'ai dû
franchir très tôt dans la vie j'ai perdu
mon meilleur ami à l'âge de 9 ans
s'appelait mathias il était venu me
chercher pour aller au ski c'était juste
après noël et j'avais eu un circuit
télécommandé comme un con je lui dis que
je préfère rester jouissent les sorties
la chaussé ses skis
il a heurté un arbre juste là en dessous
de chez moi il est mort là en dessous de
chez moi depuis ce jour là la vie n'a pu
été pareil j'ai très vite été confronté
au côté éphémère de la vie mais j'ai
surtout pris conscience que mon jeu
favori le ce qui venait de tuer mon
meilleur ami j'ai l'impression que
l'amplitude des émotions qui vont de la
peur de mourir à la joie d'être vivants
ont fait prendre conscience de la beauté
de la vie normale et et c'est pas
vraiment ce qu'on vit qui compte c'est
plutôt de le vivre pleinement comme là
bas je le vis pleinement et les peurs si
elles font partie intégrante de nos vies
de ma vie n ont jamais été maître de mes
décisions
j'ai toujours su dépasser plutôt que de
devenir leurs esclaves
ma victoire en fait n'a pas été d'avoir
été champion du monde de freeride mais
d'avoir su dépasser mes inhibitions ans
ne maîtrisons face à mes peurs
aujourd'hui donc mes peurs sont une
source de l'énergie pour dépasser mes
limites et je vous dis j'ai un truc en
plus je vous faire découvrir tout ça
ceux ci en a qu'on peut encore vu les
images
d'ailleurs en parlant de ski ça me
permet comme je suis dernier a passé je
me permets en plus le truc en faire un
peu de prévention cet hiver arrive à
grands pas et je suis le premier à avoir
envie d'aller skier donc s'il vous plaît
pensez à un truc arva pelle sonde tout
ça dans un sac à dos qui se gonfle sa
proie de sauver la vie l'astuce est bien
t'en servir recevra peut-être la vie de
ton pote donc et si on accompagne les
images
l'avalanche a eu quand même quelques uns
donc je vais vous montrer un peu parce
que avec moi vous avez vu la mort en
direct et je vais vous montrer juste
après ce coup d'état
[Musique]
j'avais pas droit sorti du rouge
donc là c'est quand ça se passe mal là
et là d'un seul coup tu t'imagines que
tu vas t'en sortir donc tu fais tout ce
que tu as appris à faire tu pars tout
droit tu prends de la vitesse est là je
devais la droite sur l'écran en
regardant à droite à gauche ans client
est en fait il ya toute la montagne qui
est en train de partir
je me rends compte parce que la caméra
est accrochée sur moi et là quand je me
rends compte je me dis va surtout pas à
droite et donc je tombe et lâche panique
là je me relève et j'ai une montagne qui
m'arrive dans la gueule voilà donc là
c'est l'enfer réellement tourner dans
tous les sens c'est plus vous êtes
jusqu'au moment où ça s'arrête
jusqu'au moment ça s'arrête et avec moi
donc vous avez vu la mort en direct mais
je vous racontais ce que vous avez pas
vu et on va le faire en musique tient
d'ailleurs ça se fait que la musique ça
fait toujours plus jouer les émotions
moi ça fait à l'intérieur à dix on
regarde tac et là dessus on monte le
volume
c'est bien ce que tu as un peu dur pour
moi je la sujet vous raconter j'ai
jamais raconté devant personne et avec
toute cette salle de remplir tout d'elle
c'est pas facile mais voilà ce que vous
avez pas vu en fait si vous n'avez pas
vu si cette dernière minute de vie ces
dernières minutes de vie où on pense à
tous mes atouts absolument tous les
proches
évidemment et tous ces moments de
bonheur passé auprès des siens et on se
dit merde [ __ ] et mais pas maintenant
pas comme ça pas déjà j'ai encore trop
de trucs à faire avoir à découvrir à
goûter à aimer à partager la tue pour ça
tout ce que tu quittes brutalement
vraiment d'un seul coup sans même dire
au revoir
tous les proches derrière lé là le
moment qui marque une vie
et ensuite il ya cette satanée dernière
seconde elle est longue
elle est tellement on sait qu'on va la
faire en soutien c'est vrai on va faire
ensemble
imagine-toi la maison temps là dessous
tout simplement sur son lit de mort qui
peut plus bouger tu peux plus parler
peut plus rien faire
tu sais que tu vas partir
et tu regrettes toutes les colères tous
les moments perdus dans des disputes
inutiles tout ce temps perdu
tous les trucs que tu aurais dû faire
avant de mourir là tu regrettes tu as tu
vraiment alors les y pense bien peu
pensez-y fermer les yeux si et de vous
imprégner du truc recense que j'ai pu
ressentir je te souhaite pas en fait je
le souhaite pas mais en fait si car le
moment où la mort arrive tu la sens
venir s mais là elle se met juste à côté
de toi
elle est là un côté toyal hésite elle
hésite
jusqu'à ce qu'elle me susurre à
l'oreille maintenant elle l'a fait deux
fois le team agit alors je la remercie
je remercie parce que à cet instant
précis je suis devenu plus que vivant et
manque de pot pour toi pour toi pour toi
pour toi pour toute la salle entière
doit tous le vivre un jour ce moment-là
ce rideau noir qui va tomber comme une
scène de théâtre y aura pas de rappel
c'est un rideau noir d'un seul coup
c'est fini il y aura pas de rappel
même moi je sais pas pourquoi je suis
encore là plusieurs c'est vrai alors
pensez-y bien on sera tous à tous vos
proches tout ce que vous avez quitté
d'un seul coup
et comme je disais j'ai même pas
pourquoi je suis là c'est peut-être pour
ça en quatre
pour transmettre
on va faire faire un indice on pas ce
que je préfère pleurer toute la salle
non plus hein
aujourd'hui en tout cas chaque seconde
qui passe le doigt est une seconde de
bonheur intense est positif et si tout
le monde se faisait un devoir d'être de
retour dias tu es de bonne humeur
moi je pense que le monde tournerait
plus on est pas d'accord bon ben là
c'est a envie batwa sourit à la vie si
je suis là c'est juste pour mettre cette
graine de positif dans la tête en fait
alors j'aurais jamais dû remonter sur
des skis et moi j'y suis retournée et
plus que jamais ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que tu as qu une vie vraiment
pas qu'une vie prenez-en conscience et
qui n'est pas utile d'être confronté à
la mort pour comprendre la beauté de la
vie n'attend pas cette dernière minute
pour te rendre compte que chaque seconde
qui passe est une seconde de bonheur
intenses et positives que t'as pas le
droit de la laisser filer son ans
savoure et l'intensité la magie le
moment présent ce très important je sais
pas la situation en fait dans laquelle
tu es qui fait de ta vie un enfer -
parade c'est juste la manière de
l'aborder de la vivre la savourer de
réagir et de sourire à chaque situation
j'ai fait la qualité du vent au passé si
tu souris à la vie lazovic fourrure a
tout simplement ma vie est une avalanche
perpétuelle je n'ai jamais eu aucun
repère dans le monde professionnel
j'ai tout appris en autodidacte ça m'a
coûté cher d'ailleurs alors j'ai fait
appel à des coachs et les mentors et je
me suis battu je me suis basé sur les
valeurs qui m'ont été transmises par le
sport cette méthodologie de la gagne
inhérentes à chaque discipline et tout
bon sportif
elle est simple c'est de la vibes
sourire du travail du travail du travail
du plaisir du plaisir et du plaisir ça
donne quoi
des médailles et des victoires c'est un
peu court comme enseignement on sait que
le travail et le plaisir ça fait gagner
la vraie question en fait c'est pourquoi
est-ce qu'on travaille d'arrache-pied
comment est ce qu'on prend du plaisir à
re que le niveau d'exigence est super
élevé que les conditions sont pourris et
que les collègues sont tous des cons ça
vous rappelle quelque chose
voilà donc en fait je me suis rendu
compte que le business et comment qu'on
fait
il ya des règles aussi un peu différente
car dans ce monde là le fair-play
n'existe pas tout le monde veut la place
de l'autre et fait tout pour l'avoir
coûte que coûte toute l'année tous les
jours
pas un seul jour de ride entre potes on
peu choquant je me suis rendu compte que
je pouvais imaginer mes journées au même
rythme qu une complète de freeride sauf
que nous on ride entre potes ce ça la
différence alors depuis cape tous les
matins je me réveille et je prends le
départ de verbier
c'est la finale de la coupe du monde du
moins c'est dans ma tête ça commence dès
le réveil tu sais que c'est cette nuit à
t'imaginer et aligne et là je vais aller
sur une triple c'est une grosse triple
il faut que je replace parce que sinon
je suis mort là qu'ils connaissent
verbier qui s'il connaît pas vers des
voies la balle orange et vous imaginez
le truc un peu verviers c'est la finale
de la coupe du monde du freeride world
tour du permier c'est un tas de cailloux
en pique comme ça tu montes à pied ja
c'est super chiant tu arrives en haut tu
as cru que c'était fini mais non il
reste encore des corps des machins
s'était remis en alpinisme et la touche
aux tests kitano un petit portillon de
départ qui ont métal machin tu as un mec
qui dit elle est inquiète tu chausse tes
skis tu regarde par terre ajoute un tu
vois ta spatule comme ça et là tu vois
la ligne d'arrivée ça peut paraître
comme ça à quoi donc
donc du coup tu dors pas bien têtu
guitton prévisionnel tu regardes la
concurrence et une mise tout parce que
l'opération de ta vie bat verbier c'est
tout pareil
la veille t'as pas envie de dormir tu as
envie de vomir en réalité tu joues ta
vie donc chaque détail compte
donc tu étudies bon business j'ai fait
pareil j'ai tout appris sur internet
j'ai regardé des tuto sur youtube
quelques fois sur youporn c'était pour
le côté plaisir
en tout cas je me suis entraîné je suis
entraîné je me suis qualifié pour le
voir le tour des emmerdes et je peux
dire j'y suis allée jusqu'au bout des
emmerdes
quoi de plus naturel que d'être légitime
pour pouvoir parler de quelque chose
c'est comme en sport sans tomberont
qu'on apprend alors j'ai travaillé
travaillé des nues en thiérache pour
arriver jusque dans la cour des grands
certes avec beaucoup de problématiques
mais surtout beaucoup de solutions et
appliqué
vj appliquent les mêmes règles l'analyse
la sécurité la persévérance la
détermination la résilience la
résilience une faculté que le sport nous
apprend la résilience définition la
résidence est l'art de naviguer dans les
torrents là parce qu'ils savent être
jolie de naviguer parce que ça doit être
fluide et doctorants parce que malgré
les emmerder l'imprévu et ben tu dois
savoir garder son sang froid face à
l'urgence d'une situation
et d'ailleurs ce soir il ya urgence donc
on va voir garder son sang froid
c'est facile on a le feront sûrement
fait ça va secouer un petit peu mais
tout va bien se terminer je vous promets
en fait j'ai décidé de diffuser toutes
mes belles idées au travers d'une web
série the lights ventures
elle est participative donc là en fait
vous êtes tous filmés vous ai déjà tous
dans marianne donc je vous proposais
participer de clôturer cette éthique
sans un peu de bruit tous ensemble parce
qu'on a dit de réveiller la salle afin
pour clôturer le tedx donc je vais vous
demander de participer c'est très simple
ou à faire un peu de mou et tous
ensemble commencez à vous échauffer je
voudrais pas qu est blessé et c'est
facile en fait y'a un petit secret le
secret c'est de se marrer normalement je
vais juste la vidéo pour que ça lieu tac
voilà il ya un secret c'est de se marrer
on va le faire ensemble
je vous proposais de fer 1er podium 1er
podium c'est que tu vas gagner un titre
de champion du monde mais juste pour
rire moi je faire ensemble
la teigne vidéo d'un vrai podium donc je
propose de gagner un titre de champion
du monde et je te laisse pas le choix
parce qu'il n'ya pas de râleur il n'y a
que des mecs content et qu'on parlera de
faire la gueule parce que sinon tu le
fais en souriant d'accord sinon c'est
comment ok tu sors pendant cinq minutes
je t'explique tu va lever les bras
progressivement elle jouait raconte
investi la foire vous échauffer là je
vous sens tous un peu éteint mais le
changement peut se réveiller quand même
vous avez les lever les bras
progressivement pour arriver en faisant
du bruit bien sûr tout en haut
et quand on sera là parce que juste
après on va arriver sur une marche de
podium en fait je fais faire un podium
avec moi là on sent là et bien là tu
donneras tout parce que ce sera là que
tu seras sur la première marche du
podium et je te demande juste de tout et
c'est très simple j'ai le droit de vous
lever c'est d'un phare nouvelle droit de
vous lever c'est très simple on va on va
essayer de faire un truc ensemble et en
plus de ça si je peux me permettre
j'ai quelques petites astuces c'est
simple sinon c'est des petites astuces
que je vous donne pour quand vous
sortirez dit si je vous demande juste de
donner de l'amour d'être bienveillant et
de transmettre de l'énergie positive des
bonnes ondes et de la bonne vibes c'est
la base de tout était prêt de preuves
quoi bon alors on va regarder la vidéo
et en même temps on va tout donner parce
que là c'est la fin donc on donne tout
donc c'est parti là dis toi que tu es en
train d'arriver sur un podium et on va
s'échauffer un petit peu parce que quand
on annonce pour aller rivés sur un
podium tu vas plus voir un peu faire
chaud
la sauce vous entend pas assez là je
vous tapez les pieds d'un cas en train
d'arriver sur le podium on t'appelle
et là tu commences à y aller alors date
des pieds table et jaden tous là benq ça
donne tout tu es le meilleur donne le
meilleur de toi même au corps a encore
j'entends pas le droit de reims et de
faire du bruit
darif to check check années 30 et
d'énergie la vie est belle avait rêvé
d'être vécue box un jeu de l'amour du
saut et à ta joie de mur et tout c'est
quoi ta se trompe mais ces combattants
tchèque le jeu une vague de cech
genevac de cech faut s'acheter partout
merci à vous la vie tout simplement
environ 100 mais fixer des objectifs
assez haut n'oublie jamais se fixer les
objets qui pas assez haut
tu connais la formule n'appartient qu'à
toi de passer une bonne journée mais
faire bonne journée une [ __ ] de super
bonne journée moi j'ai décelé sauver le
monde en diffusant du bonnet à la bonne
humeur et avoir vos gueules
on dirait bien que ça marche et je
rappelle juillet à lopez bien si bas en
fait vivre
[Applaudissements]